Thanks Nick.
Here on this Android device we have an
activity with an element that we want to
change, namely this text field here.
So let's switch over to Android Studio
to see how we can do this in code.
In the project window here,
under this folder called values.
We have a file called styles.xml,
this holds the default theme for
this application called AppTheme.
As we can see, we have no customized
properties in our AppTheme.
As we can see from this parent property,
AppTheme derived from
Theme.AppCompat.Light.DarkActionBar.
Now, let's look at some of
the properties that make up
this DarkActionBar theme.
So there are a couple
of ways to do this.
So if we right-click and
go down to Go To, and
then Implementation or
you can Ctrl+Click.
So we see the style right here.
The Theme.AppCompat.Light.DarkActionBar.
That derived from
Base.Theme.AppCompat.Light
DarkActionBar.
So if we go to that one, we can see
there a couple of properties here.
Some of the interesting ones here
are the colorPrimaryDark and
the colorPrimary.
Now, you can go and see what those
colors are by doing another Ctrl+Click.
And we see right here that,
that corresponds to a black color.
So now,
that we're back in our styles.xml file,
let's create a new style.
So in this code right here,
we have a style called MyStyle
that assigned a greenish type
color to android:textColor.
So now, that we have our style,
let's assign it to an actual element.
So if we go back into our project view,
let's go to layout > activity_main.
So here's the text view
that we previously had
that shows up as a grayish color.
Let's go in here.
So in these text views declaration,
we just need to add this last
line here where we say the style
is equal to @style/MyStyle.
And that's referring to the style that
we created before called, MyStyle.
One thing that you notice is
the style property right here,
isn't appended with an android:.
So if we go over to the design view,
we can see this green color here for
Hello world!